Now that we have our bedroom
properties., I want to talk about
a couple more property attribute
you'll see here alongside nonatomic.
The attributes strong and weak.
We could have written our bedroom
properties like this, but
we didn't actually bother writing strong
because pointers are strong by default.
Although there are some development
teams who always write strong
just to be extra explicit.
So when should a reference to a property
be strong, and when should it be weak?
Strong references are used for
properties that are the primary
responsibility of the class.
In other words, owned by the class.
These bedrooms are owned
by the house class.
Weak references are used for
properties that are the primary
responsibility of some other class.
There are two times when you should
use weak references for properties.
When the property is a delegate and
when the property is
a subview of the main view.
Take note, this is important
to avoid memory cycles.
For more information on
what causes memory cycles,
check out the links in
the accompanying text.